if you didn't know I bloody love
resident evil not all of them I'm not a
madman I know there has been many
terrible games in the series as there
has been masterpieces Resident Evil 6
I'm looking at you
Resident Evil 7 is the most gruesome and
gory entry in the series the spectacular
where you murder the Baker family is one
thing and the encounters where you fail
is just as good wrenching so grab a sick
bucket make sure you haven't eaten for a
few hours and enjoy ten ways to die in
Resident Evil 7 if you haven't guessed
this already
this will definitely contain spoilers
don't watch you have been warned the
first death in Resident Evil 7 sets the
scene perfectly and as you're looking
for your wife what better place to start
in his gorefest then with Ethan killing
the woman he actually came here to save
to be honest he didn't start this fight
and even took a knife through the hand
before fighting back his weapon of
choice and axe to the neck Mia does not
take kindly to being killed and gains
revenge on her husband by first stick in
a screwdriver through his hand and then
cuts his hand off with a chainsaw she
just so happened to stumble across
Ethan can escape this encounter and when
he's about to climb to his freedom
through the window in swoops lovely wife
Mia and continues her newfound love of
heavy machinery
if Ethan somehow survives Mia's
courtship his hand is reattached to his
arm by the lovely Baker family who we
even cook him a meal southern
hospitality at its finest
Athens next attempt to leave is assisted
by a police officer who kindly opens the
garage door but Jack doesn't like
uninvited guests Jack rightfully sees
the officer as a threat and subdues him
with a shovel through the school every
day I'm shoveling Ethan is next on
Jack's hit list having both his arm
broken and then his neck snapped this
game is absolutely brutal oh you are
nothing just a man
our next encounter with Jack involves a
chainsaw and what looks like a chainsaw
a pair of scissors should Jack get the
upper hand in this fight then Ethan
could lose both his arms Andy's head
but if Ethan comes out on top
prepare your eyes for this gruesome
death
do me a favor and stay dead at this
point I was going to include Marguerite
Baker but for two words vagina insects
nope nope uh-uh
move on in one of the VHS tapes you pick
up you can witness the death of one of
the demo characters Clancy in a soft
style murder scene he is first impaled
with a nail and quilt that's one of
those pen things in it from he Aldi
times he then has loser camp into his
arm and finally he is set ablaze for
some reason his cries at fen sound more
like someone who has been sat down for
too long on their leg and trying to
stand up with pins and needles no is it
just me
[Music]
when Jack makes his return he's changed
a bit but in a pretty cool boss fight
ethan blinds him by shooting all his
eyes
finally he's dead but he has one final
attack in him to end this encounter he
just simply inject him with a cure but
if you wait a little bit too long
he decapitates even allowing you to
witness his now headless dead body
depending who you choose to save earlier
in the game
you have to fight me yet again
[Music]
thank you in that time this time you
have your trusty crowbar and it's a game
of cat and mouse until either Mia stabs
you through the heart or Ethan embeds
his crowbar in Mia's chest if this is
what married life is all about I cannot
wait to be wet
[Applause]
why finally after you uncover the
mystery of aunt Rodie the final battle
of the game ensues it's surprisingly
easy and rather uneventful so many
people haven't seen the death animation
well feast your eyes on this
ethan is literally eaten by a massive
head of an old woman I can certainly say
I wasn't expecting that
so that's it that's ten ways to die in
Resident Evil seven if you've enjoyed
this video like the mad person you are
please get some counselling but only
after you've pressed like and subscribed
of course we have a lots more of these
gory videos so please check one out if
you're that way inclined I'm adding from
first station grenades
I'll see you next time
[Music]